I've been running scams on the street
since I was 10 just kicked out of flight
Academy for having a mind in my own
I'm gonna be a pilot
the best in the galaxy
hey kid I'm putting together a crew
you win that's yes
that might be the only person
who knows
what you really are
[Music]
what's happened
get ready now we're in trouble there for
a second but it's fine we're fine
[Music]
hey everybody they finally dropped the
full Star Wars trailer we got a much
better picture of Alden Ehrenreich
performances Han Solo which is obviously
going to drive the entire film like
there's a lot of cool things in Star
Wars films the aliens are always cool
the creatures are always cool but with
the character like Han Solo that's so
ingrained in the minds of people like
you can imagine the way that people
reacted to Luke Skywalker recently in
the pantheon of characters han Solo is
up there too and when she says I know
who you really are and she's like what's
that you just hear everybody across the
world at the same time say he's a
scoundrel that's who he is that's his
archetype there's still a lot of
characters that we don't know a whole
lot about but we did finally get a look
at Dan D Newton's character we found out
a little bit more about Kyra's character
I'm just gonna pronounce the name that
way I'm sure it's a little bit different
we'll get a little more information
about that when they start doing the
press tour or they start doing
interviews about their characters
specifically but you to get a better
picture of how the group comes together
and that's really the important part of
the film so it sounds like all the stuff
that the imperial academy happens
relatively early in the film and is over
pretty quick because he says I got
kicked out for having a mind of my own
which might wind up tying into how he
meets Chewbacca because I am expecting
some minor edits to what we know from
Canon because they talked about it
they've shown it like very briefly but
for the most part most Han Solo stories
have taken place after he's become an
adult there was a novel in more recent
years before Disney bought the company
where a character named garish Shrike
sort of Shepherds him along he was sort
of the woody harrelson of that story
this character is obviously a little bit
different his name is Beckett but he's
the person that brings them together I'm
putting a crew together that probably
has something to do with the Kessel run
and we get a much better look at that -
there's like this giant space creature
we don't really know what this is either
this seems to be something new - we know
a lot about Kessel the planet we know
about the spice mines but we don't know
about the circumstances of the Kessel
run itself only that it was part of a
smugglers run we just know him as a
smuggler like that's how he was
introduced in the story so most of the
legends stories with Han Solo dealt with
his children like it was actually moving
forward in the timeline you know not a
whole lot of backstory you also probably
noticed some weird stuff going on with
the Millennium Falcon's design
so it actually doesn't have the two
prongs up to the front it's really just
has this extra piece in between the two
prongs so at some point that might get
knocked out this sort of this running
gag in Star Wars movies where the bullet
iam Falken always winds up bumping into
something and knocking a piece of it off
usually it's the deflector dish but who
knows what function this serves so you
guys could post all your theories in the
comments below really cool least rate -
we got a confirm shot of the dice from
the Millennium Falcon so this looks like
it's before he takes that ship so I'm
guessing that you know whenever they go
on the Kessel run that's when the dice
land on the Millennium Falcon so it'll
be fun to see where he originally got
those from but I do love some of the
wardrobe here obviously Lando always has
the best wardrobe he was supposed to be
the most super fly dude in the galaxy
but I love her red and black cape here
it makes her seem a little more sinister
than she probably actually is but
because we see the droid walking behind
her and then we also see it just sort of
like mimicking Lando later in the
trailer we don't really know where it
comes from
if it belongs to Lando or if it belongs
to her we actually found out that the
droid here is called l3 37 or Lee's we
know whatever the shorthand is going to
be for we'll find out pretty soon but
she's being played by this actress here
so it is a female droid but like with a
lot of rogue 1 characters yet to
preemptively pour one out for them
because it's like well if they're not
alive in present day then something
probably pretty bad happens to them
during the course of the movie you know
usually they make you fall in love with
the character but by the end of the
movie when he sacrifices himself you're
completely heartbroken I'm just worried
they might miss you
doesn't sound so bad to me we recently
found out that Thandi Newton's character
is called Val she just looks like
another smuggler that gets tied up in
this group we don't know much about her
backstory or anything like that but
after seeing her character on Westworld
you kind of know what she's capable of
which is funny too because they dropped
the west-world season 2 trailer which
I'll totally do a video for next but
before we got some of these details I
actually wondered if Paul Bettany was
gonna wind up playing one of the droids
but I do like the idea that he doesn't
just continue playing droid characters
like he's playing vision in the Marvel
Universe so it makes sense they bring
him into this they try to do something a
little bit different with him because
he's a great classical actor but he
joined the film relatively late so I
don't know how big his role is going to
be but Ron Howard just seemed to have
this crazy ability to shoot a ton of
footage in a short amount of time
there's this weird funny crosstalk
that's happening under the Disney
umbrella because they own both Star Wars
and Marvel so you have these really big
actors just bouncing around from
franchise to franchise like even Donald
Glover is a relatively memorable
character from the Marvel Universe
because the spider-man homecoming now we
get a much better shot of that bounty
hunter that he's fighting on top of the
Train in that previous version of the
trailer we don't know who his character
is but there is somebody on the IMDB
page this is just credited as a marauder
that's probably who these people are the
two really big things that we don't see
in the trailer are Boba Fett or the huts
I'll be interested to see if they're
anywhere in the film I wouldn't be
surprised if there's like a little bit
of it nobody said anything official
about Boba Fett's involvement in the
film but you cannot call yourself a
smuggler in the Star Wars galaxy without
bumping into the Hutt syndicate at some
point so even if we don't get Jabba
we'll probably get some form of the
Hutts
it even though his backstory is still
spun out in legend so who knows if it's
still canon but Jabba is not the biggest
baddest Hutt that there ever was his
father Zorba the Hutt was way richer way
batter and way worse than he ever was so
I think a lot of us are just waiting to
see what they brought forward from
legends because this is such a big
character and even though they haven't
delved into Han Solo's backstory to the
level that they have with the Skywalker
family because we got the prequel films
there's still some generally accepted
backstory points for his character like
he comes from Corellia he's
not a force user so I'm hoping that even
though they have this new thing with the
way they're treating the force in the
new Star Wars films where there's like
this low level ability of people to tap
into it even if you're not a Jedi this
is the only film that I hope that they
leave that out of like they can make
jokes about it because when we get to a
new hope han Solo completely does not
believe in an all-powerful force
controlling people's destiny as he says
but that's because of the choices that
he made so you'll see that play out
during the film like he says that he has
a mind of his own so we'll probably see
some of those moments where he takes
control of his own destiny like he's not
listening to the force in the way that
Luke Skywalker would try to listen to
the force so I'm just I'm hoping that
even if there are characters who are
force sensitive in the film the way that
Donnie Yen was force sensitive during
rogue one that they don't try to imply
that Han Solo's piloting ability has
anything to do with his connection to
the force because that's like a
long-running joke in the Star Wars
fandom is is that maybe he used the
force at some point and just didn't
realize it just because you don't
believe in something doesn't mean that
it doesn't exist so let me know in the
comments below what do you want them to
bring forward from legends and do you
think that they do include Hutt's as
well as Boba Fett in the film somewhere
even if they're not big parts of the
film the interesting thing that happened
on the video that I posted yesterday is
that a lot of you guys were actually
cautiously optimistic about the movie
after seeing the footage whereas you
know last year it was like this crazy
story behind the scenes of Ron Howard
having to come in on the film because
they fired Lord and Miller
we'll never know what the Lord and
Miller cut looked like but we can wonder
about it when we watch the movie in a
couple months but if they pull this off
it will be the craziest hat trick ever
so what's gonna happen next is I'll do a
Westworld season 2 video but they also
dropped that JJ Abrams movie Cloverfield
paradox so I'll try to do a video for
that too there's just a whole bunch of
Super Bowl stuff to get through so make
sure you subscribe to get everything and
leave all your Star Wars bonus video
requests in the comments below but while
you wait for everything click here to
rewatch that infinity war trailer a
billion more times and click here for my
episode 9 video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight